Your app might run on the iPhone Duo, but that
doesn't mean it's ready. There's a huge difference
between an app that works on the iPhone Duo and
one that feels specifically designed for it. So,
what do you need to do to get your app ready?
That's what I'm breaking down in this video,
including something cool about the hinge
that opens up opportunities for brand new
app ideas. All right, let's start with the big
one. Your app is going to have six brand new
layout configurations to support with the
iPhone Duo, but you don't build six different
UIs for your app. You're going to support the
same size classes you may already be familiar
with with compact and regular. And the iPhone
Duo has various combinations of these. There's
the compact width, regular height, which is the
typical iPhone combination. But there's a new one,
compact compact. When the iPhone Duo is closed
and in landscape, that's going to be a new one
we have to support. And when the Duo is unfolded,
we get that regular regular size class combination
that we're already used to with the iPad.
So, if your app already fully supports iPad,
you're going to be most of the way there. Now,
I want to be clear. I said fully supports iPad.
That means multitasking, resizability, multiple
instances of your app, landscape, split view,
and I'd argue that even though most apps work on
the iPad, fully supporting the iPad is a different
story. So, you're probably going to have some work
to do here because the last thing you want is just
a stretched out version of your iPhone app when
the user unfolds the Duo. So to implement these
changes, you're going to want to check the
environment values for horizontal size class
and vertical size class and then adapt your UI
accordingly. For example, if on a typical iPhone
layout, you have views that are vertically
stacked on top of each other, maybe you flip
that to horizontally stacked when you're in the
regular regular size class configuration. Or you
can use split view to flatten out your navigation
hierarchy if that makes sense for your app or use
the sidebar configuration for your tab view if
it's information dense. So, if you've been hard-
coding view widths in your app, or maybe you
disabled landscape mode because you just didn't
want to deal with that, not anymore. It's time
to fully support that. But on the bright side,
in fully supporting all this, the multitasking,
the split views, the multiple instances of your
app, landscape mode, you're going to end up with
a really good, fully supported iPad app. So,
it's kind of like a two for one deal. The iPhone
Duo Simulator is shipping with Xcode 27.1,
which Apple says will ship in late September
of 2026. So, if you're watching this before,
then you're going to have to wait a little bit
before you can fully test out all these APIs and
see what your app really looks like on the Duo
simulator. Xcode 27.1 also introduces a new AI
agent skill for resizability. So, that should
help adapt your app for the iPhone Duo. And
this is what apps are going to look like that
are not built with iOS 27 SDK or above. Not a
great look. So, older apps that are no longer
updated are really going to stand out on this
device. So hopefully some of your competitors
are doing that, but you you need to build on
the iOS 27 SDK and above and your app will start
looking like this. Start looking like it actually
supports the iPhone Duo. Of course, you may have
to do a little more work to make it look great,
but building for the iOS 27 SDK is going to be a
great start. Now, let's talk about your toolbars
and tab views because they're going to have to
adjust from the horizontal layout to the vertical
layout and back on the fly depending on what
configuration your user has their iPhone Duo in.
And the biggest tip here, which is what I've been
saying for years, for situations just like this,
use the native components, use built-in
navigation stack, use the default tab view,
use the built-in toolbar API. When you use
these, most of the work to support the iPhone
Duo is already done for you. But if you built your
own custom toolbar or your own custom tab view,
you're you're going to have a lot of work ahead
of you. And I just recommend during that work,
just switch to the native components. You're going
to save yourself so much time and headache. And
honestly, with liquid glass, they look great.
But of course, even if you're using the native
components, there's still some small nuances and
customization you can do. For example, if you have
a tab view and a toolbar with a few buttons, those
are going to go on the side along with the status
bar and the live activities. So, if you have a
lot of toolbar buttons, you're going to run out
of room pretty quickly. To handle this, you need
to adopt the new toolbar overflow API that was
introduced in iOS 27. This is where the toolbar or
tab view options will collapse into a menu button,
and you can adjust which should collapse first.
Maybe your toolbar buttons are more important
than your tab view and you want the tab view to
collapse first. Well, you can configure that with
the toolbar vertical compression behavior API. You
can also give individual toolbar items their own
priority if there's certain buttons you don't want
to go into the overflow menu. And you can set this
with the visibility priority API. Another nuance
to consider with the vertical toolbars is that the
order matters top to bottom. That means you want
the primary action to be up top, any prominent
actions to be right below, and any secondary
ones below that. For example, when you're in
a navigation stack, the back button is the top
button and then the prominent action is right
below. And if you have texton buttons in your
toolbar, those are going to stay up top in the
horizontal toolbar because they're wide. There's
not enough room in the vertical toolbar. So, Apple
recommends a couple of ways to deal with this.
The first is to try and avoid texton buttons when
you can and use Swift UI labels which allow you to
give a text and an icon. That way, the system has
the flexibility to determine where it should go.
For example, by default, icon only buttons will
go in the vertical toolbar and the texton buttons
will go in the horizontal toolbar. But even when
an icon button goes into the overflow menu, well,
that menu will now show the icon and the text. So,
when you use a Swift UI label, you're giving the
system what it needs to properly show your action
no matter the context. But if you absolutely
need a texton button, it's going to go in the
horizontal toolbar. And if there's any related
buttons, you should keep them next to it. So,
Apple does give you a way to prefer the horizontal
toolbar, even for icon only buttons. And for this,
you can use the access behavior API. Here are
some other things to consider for your toolbar. If
you have an icon with a number next to it, like a
cart or an inbox, consider using the badge API to
clean that up. Don't add additional spacing in the
vertical toolbar with toolbar spacers. And that's
because the vertical screen real estate is already
limited. So, let the system do it. And in special
cases where it makes sense to not use a vertical
toolbar, like the calculator app, you can disable
that behavior with the toolbar vertical behavior
API. And if you've built a custom toolbar and you
want to know when to flip that to the vertical
version of it, you can check the toolbar vertical
edge environment value and adjust accordingly.
Now, let's talk about the hinge. The hinge is what
makes the iPhone Duo special. It's literally the
backbone. And in your code, you can get a highle
status like open, closed, or partially open. And
you can even get continuous data on the actual
angle of the hinge in real time. And this opens
the door for all kinds of app ideas or feature
ideas or fun animations. For example, this video
player app is showing a dynamic reflection of
the content on the bottom part of the screen
based on the hinge angle. Apple demonstrated
a toy app they made where the hinge can act
as a whammy for guitar. You strum the guitar
strings and then move the hinge back and forth
to adjust the pitch bend. Like listen to this.
Not going to lie, that's pretty cool. And
then here's a little code snippet of what
the onhinge change modifier looks like. Now,
of course, that's a fun little toy, but do some
brainstorming. I bet you could come up with some
really cool things to do in your app. And even
though it may sound silly, things like this have
worked before when adapting your UI to the various
poses the iPhone Duo is capable of. There are
certain areas you're going to need to adjust to,
like the fold in the center of the screen or
the inner and outer cameras. These are called
reserved regions and your UI needs to adapt to
them. For example, if something is in the center
of the phone when it's unfolded, it should move
to one side when partially folded. Or view should
adjust their size so they are split evenly when
partially folded. Essentially, you don't want
your content or controls to be obstructed by the
fold. And if you're using native containers like
navigation stack, split view, tab view, list,
scroll view, adjusting to the reserve regions,
that's built right in. However, if you need to
handle this manually, Apple gives us some APIs to
do that. You can access the regions, their frame
dimensions and whether the region is active or not
with geometry reader. And there are two types of
reserved regions. There's dot division which is
the fold and then there's dot occlusion which
are the outer and inner cameras. And these can
either be active, for example, when the fold
is partially folded or inactive when the duo
is fully unfolded. And like I said, the built-in
containers like navigation stack, they handle this
out of the box. But if you do need a custom view
to do it, Apple gave us a new container called
layout container. And a layout container takes in
something called an arrangement to determine how
to handle the fold. An arrangement can either
be a split or an overlay depending on the type
of UI you need. An arrangement takes in inputs and
gives outputs. Examples of inputs can be what size
class configuration we're currently in. What's the
aspect ratio? What are the reserved regions? And
then based on that input, you can declare whether
you want to show a view at all. And if you do want
to show it, you can declare the frame. And Apple
gives us various system arrangements that we can
use in our apps. Here's some example code showing
an arrangement view in the split configuration.
There's also a new safe area to take into account
and that is the horizontal safe area and these
behave just as the normal safe areas we're used
to except it's just on the side now but this is
where the vertical toolbar will go. So you can
have a full bleed background or background image
using the ignore safe area modifier but just
make sure your content and anything scrolling
respects that safe area so it doesn't get
covered up by the vertical toolbar. All right,
here's some quick hitting small stuff to wrap up.
Standby mode is going to be used a lot more as you
can see in some of these examples. And I bet a lot
of you developers out there maybe neglected full
standby mode adoption for your widgets. Well,
now's the time. Fix that. Apple Pencil support
is coming later this year. So, if your app can
take advantage of that, better start research
and pencil kit. Use the concentric rectangle
API to make sure any custom background matches
the asymmetric shape of the front screen. Your
sheets are going to appear differently depending
on the various poses. And then you might want
to think about drag and drop because if you were
building just an iPhone only app and you didn't
fully support the iPad like I talked about with
multitasking side by side, you probably weren't
worried about drag and drop into your iPhone app.
Well, now that your app is going to be able to be
side by side with any other app if it makes sense
for your app, you might want to think about
fully supporting drag and drop because users
are going to be expecting it. And if you want to
dive deeper into all of this, Apple released six
videos all about building for the iPhone Duo and
they've updated their human interface guidelines
with a special section for it. I'll put the links
to those in the description. And if you're trying
to build an amazing app for the iPhone Duo or
just Apple platforms in general, you should check
out Bitrig. It's an AI development environment
specifically focused on building premium Swift
apps for Apple platforms. It's actually built by
the co-creators of Swift UI that were formerly at
Apple. So, it integrates amazingly well with the
first party Apple frameworks and it specializes
in Swift and Swift UI. And it will know about all
these new APIs and best practices for supporting
the iPhone Duo. It can also create and manage
your app store connect listing, set up your inapp
purchases or subscriptions, and even submit to
the app store for you. The team ships updates on
a weekly basis, so the product is constantly
getting better. Check it out at bitrig.com.